Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of time on
this because I believe there's going to be more
time for it. But one of the big questions about
2024 is is Joe Biden going to run for reelection?
I think he's not. That's my opinion as of right
now. But I could be wrong. It's just a guess. I'm
terrible at making predictions. I thought Hillary
would win in 2016, so it's just my opinion, and
it doesn't really matter. I just don't think Joe
Biden's running for reelection in 2024. The other
side of that is is Trump running for reelection in
2024. I have been leaning very heavily towards yes
for a while. When I interviewed Michael Cohen,
Trump's former lawyer, Michael Cohen, said,
I don't think Trump's going to run because he's
going to realize he can't win and his ego can't
handle another loss. OK, that's another opinion.
But one of the things I've been mentioning
is I am unsure what Trump's health is going to
look like in 2024. But he's not a healthy guy,
and he's not a particularly young guy. OK.
Just it's just actuarial. Reality is fair.
For the first time that I've ever seen, Donald
Trump is now starting to talk about his health
as a possible reason that he wouldn't run.
And the question is, regardless of the truth
about his health, is he just starting to lay the
groundwork for using health as an excuse not to
run? This is from an interesting interview in The
Washington Post with Josh Dawsey. This was from.
This is from a few days ago. The article is
called Trump Deflects Blame for January six.
Silence says he wanted to march to the Capitol.
I don't want to talk about that part of it.
I want to talk specifically about the end of
this article where Trump actually talks about
the issue of 2024 and health. Check this out.
Let's put it up on the screen. Trump said it was
true he had told advisers that his health would
factor into whether he would run again in 2024,
but that he was currently in good health. Quote
You always have to talk about health. You look
like you're in good health. But tomorrow you get
a letter from a doctor saying, Come see me again.
That's not good when they use the word again.
So this is typical Trump speak. We're we're
left wondering is is he saying this because he
already knows about a health issue or not? Or
does he just what is this about? It's cryptic.
It's always completely cryptic. But this is the
first time I'm aware of that Donald Trump has
floated. What will his health status be in 2024
as a factor? Now I've been saying it's a
factor. Obviously, if he's not healthy,
he's not going to be able to run. But Trump is now
laying it out there, and there's two perspectives.
One is there's something going on with Trump,
and this is how he's starting to allude to it.
The second perspective is this is just setting up
an excuse, but Trump has no intention of running.
What Trump wants to do is to continue dangling
that he might run the way he's been doing at
rallies, saying You're going to be very happy
in 2024. We're going to take it back in 2024,
suggesting that he's going to run in
order to keep fundraising for his PAC,
which is pretty clearly being used as a slush fund
to hire family members and who knows what else.
He has millions of reasons right now to
pretend that he's going to run in 2024,
and he may not even really be planning to do it.
We just don't know. What we do know is health,
which I've been talking about for over a year now.
Actually being mentioned by Trump as far as I know
for the first time will have more coverage of this
interview on our Instagram at David Pakman show.
And you can let us know there in a
comment. What do you think is the meaning
of this health issue being brought up by
Trump for the first time? Let us know.